تحشم منذ اسبوعين لكنها لا تحدد وقتا
للدخول البري الا تركته لاخر تخشى اسرائيل
الاشتباك المباشره في حارات غزه ولذا تقوم
بترحيل ساكنيه وتدمير بناياته لن ندخلها
ابدا ما داموا فيها شعار
المرحله يعرف جنود الاحتلال انهم لن يصلوا
الى اهدافهم بالقتل من الجو فحسب فلابد من
الاقتراب اكثر من الرجال الذين صبحو يوم
السابع من اكتوبر لكن الصداع الذي لا تكف
حكومه نتنياهو عن ذكره هو صداع
الانفاق اقتربت اسرائيل من انفاق المقاومه
في حرب
2014 وقادها ذلك الدرس الى الاستثمار
المفرط في اسالب الحرب داخلها حتى انها
بنت انفاقها الخاصه
للتدريب لم تنجح عام 2014 في هدم اكثر من
32 نفقه بينما تتحدث الان عن وجود 1300
نفق
للمقاومه خطر الانفاق انها مكان مثالي
للكر والفر والاختباء والكمائن واصطياد
الاسرى ولا وجود لاي مسيرات تستطيع كشفها
من الجو كما تمنح المقاومه وسائل اتصال
امنه تغنيها عن شبكه الهاتف المرتبطه
باسرائيل كل هذا يجعل القاده السياسيين
خائفين من مغامره الدخول فالجيش
الاسرائيلي فقد عنصر المفاجاه وهو عنصر
ضروري في مثل هذه
الظروف الجيش الاسرائيلي ليس جيدا وقد
ساءت حاله بسبب انسحابه من الادوار
الطبيعيه للجيوش الى مهام الشرطه في رام
الله فمعظم جنوده ينفقون اوقاتهم في معارك
مع الاطفال والمراهقات في شوارع رام
الله محللون اخرون يتحدثون عن الانفاق
التي صنعتها اله البطش الاسرائيليه فوق
ارض غزه هذه المره
فهذا الدمار سيتحول الى اماكن اختباء وكر
وفر لابناء هذه الحواري مع الاحتلال وهم
العارفون بها المطرودون منها ظلما وللدخول
البري ضريبته السياسيه كذلك فما الذي
ستفعل اسرائيل بعد اجتياح غزه وهل يمكن
لحلم التطبيع الذي كانت منغمسه فيه ان يجد
له سوقا بعد كل ما تقوم
به هذه الحقائق ربما تفسر تاخر نتنياهو في
دخوله البري مما جعل الاعلام الاسرائيلي
يصفه بالجبن والضعف رغم ما يحاول تسويقه
في ظهوره الاعلامي فثم فرق هائل بين ان
تقتل وان تقاتل